ساعدت هذه النظارات الرجل الأعمى على
الرؤية لأول مرة منذ
عقود ، حيث أدرك الرجل لأول مرة أنه يستطيع رؤيته عندما
كان في الخارج في نزهة ، ما كان المريض
قادرًا على فعله هو رؤية ممرات المشاة
في الشارع وكنت منتشيًا جدًا هذه
السنة 58  بدأ قديم يفقد بصره عندما
كان مراهقًا بسبب حالة وراثية
تسمى التهاب الشبكية الصباغي أو rp ، وهي
تؤثر على مليوني شخص في جميع أنحاء العالم
ولا يوجد
علاج في معظم الحالات في التهاب الشبكية الصباغي.
عادة أولئك الذين يعانون من التهاب المفاصل الروماتويدي يفقدون
بصرهم بشكل دائم ولكن العلاج الأول
من نوعه من شركة
التكنولوجيا الحيوية يشير إلى أن بعض
المواقع يمكن استعادتها
ما سمعته من المريض هو أن
هذا يعطيهم انطباعًا بأن
العين حية مرة أخرى.
يستخدم العلاج الجيني
لتغيير الخلايا في العين وتخصص
نظارات واقية لتنشيطها. الطريقة
لها أصولها في الطبيعة.
اكتشف العلماء منذ عقود
بروتينًا خاصًا مشتقًا من الطحالب يتفاعل
مع الضوء يستخدم العلماء الفيروسات
لإيصال هذه البروتينات إلى
أدمغة الحيوانات المعدلة وراثيًا
الخلايا العصبية حتى تصبح حساسة للضوء ، وهي
تقنية تسمى علم البصريات الوراثي باستخدام
الضوء يمكنهم تنشيط الخلايا العصبية
لمعرفة كيفية القيام بذلك.  يعمل الدماغ ولكن
الباحثين في Gensight أرادوا
تجربة التقنية على شبكية العين البشرية
بدا الأمر مجنونًا تمامًا لأنه كيف
يمكنك إحضار شيء من الطحالب
إلى العين ومحاولة استعادة بعض الرؤية
في عين أحد المرضى قام العلماء
بتعديل خلايا الشبكية وجعلها
حساسة للضوء الكهرماني ثم قاموا
بتصميم نظارات مدمجة
بكاميرا خاصة تحول الصور من
العالم الحقيقي إلى نبضات من الضوء الكهرماني يتم
بثها مباشرة في العين لكن
الباحثين لم يكونوا متأكدين مما إذا كان
بإمكان المرضى ترجمة هذه اللغة البصرية الجديدة
إلى البصر بعد سبعة أشهر.  حقق
تقدمًا كبيرًا
بحيث كان المريض قادرًا على الاستيلاء على
الشيء لتوجيهه  بالنسبة لهم وإحصاء
هذا هو محاكاة لما
قد يراه المريض على الأرجح أنها ليست رؤية مثالية
ولكنها
تمنحك القدرة على رؤية
حواف الأشكال لما تراه
بسبب مواقع الجائحة الوبائية
التي أجريت دراستها على مريض واحد فقط
لكن الخبراء ما زالوا يعتقدون أن النتائج المحدودة
مهمة ، فهذه
نتيجة مقنعة للغاية
على الرغم من أنها مريض واحد فقط
والآن سيركز الجهد على أي
طريقة من هذا النوع هي الأفضل وكيف
يمكنك تحسينها وستكون قادرًا على
التعرف على  وجه شخص ما ، هل
ستكون قادرًا على قراءة كيف تشعر
بضيق شديد جدًا ، فأنت جيد تسعة
مرضى حاليًا يختبرون علاج المواقع الجينية
وتعمل الشركة على
توسيع التجربة السريرية ، إنها حقبة ذهبية
للعديد من الحالات التي لم
يعتقد أحد أننا  يمكن أن نتعامل معها في بعض الأحيان
يجب أن نكون أكثر تفاؤلاً في
الحياة وعندما نكون كذلك